In the previous videos, you've seen us buying this
big piece of land and working on it.
We spend a lot of time building,
renovating and clearing the land.
But, there's one thing we never mentioned,
and it's probably the most risky thing we ever did.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update.
So, about two years ago,
we bought this big piece of land.
It's around ten hectares.
And, by far the scariest thing,
when we were buying this piece of land...
We bought it with a hole in the middle.
Let me explain.
See, this is the map of the land, and this is our land.
This big circle in the middle is not ours.
And, this circle is actually pretty big, with one hectare.
It's very close to Basekamp.
So, here we have Basekamp, and the workspace.
Here is the road,
and already here is the neighboring land.
So, all around here are the edges.
You can see it marked very well with the poles.
This is quite scary!
Buying a land that close by a neighboring land,
and really all surrounded with it.
Because, maybe the neighbor decided to start living here...
So, then they have to drive to Project Kamp every day,
which is kind of awkward.
Maybe, they start a stinky chicken farm,
so it would smell here all the time!
Or maybe, they decide to build a noisy factory...
It would really be in the middle,
like in the heart of Project Kamp.
So, it seemed like a very stupid thing,
to buy your land like that...
Not owning the middle land...
But, so far, it's actually growing quite 'well'.
So, after a year or something, when we came here...
We met the neighbor,
and we also found as well on his land.
And, we asked him:
''Could we use that for water on our land?''
And he said: "Yeah! Sure!''
Which was a good point, that we started meeting each other.
We saw they're quite friendly, and nice people,
that are happy that we're here.
I think that's kind of how we bought this land.
Just hoping that the neighbor would be okay!
I would say it's been very risky, because you never know
what neighbor you're going to end up with...
And, you have a lot of doom scenarios out there,
of people fighting with their neighbor...
Bu,t I think, deep down inside, we fully trusted on hoping
people would find our way out of this.
So, now, we made an agreement that was the next step
that we would actually buy the land, which is cool!
Still haven't officially bought it,
but I guess we both agreed!
We trust each other!
So, now we can start using the land,
but we actually haven't really properly seen it yet.
So, as a first step, we're going to discover it with a drone.
We are here and the neighboring land is here.
It's really in the middle of our land.
If you have a closer look,
it seems like some really cool things are there!
Like some ruins on the land...
Looks pretty cool from above!
And, some other hidden structures covered in bushes here...
Not sure what those are.
Some sort of a small ruin or tiny brick house...
And, with it, seems another granite ruin next to it.
Overall, it looks like it has a lot of spiky bushes and vegetation,
green areas and full of brambles.
So, yeah, that's all we can see for now with the drone.
Let's have a look on the ground and explore those structures!
I'm curious to see what they look like from close by!
So, here's the border.
We're going to have a look what's there.
A lot of mimosas around here.
A little open field.
Here's the well!
The neighbors always talked about the overflow
of our well should be somewhere here...
It's a bit wet on the bottom...
Yuck!
Wet socks!
This is the overflow of our well that we use.
And, as you can see,
the water is still flowing into the reservoir there.
Almost empty, but it's still wet in here.
Okay, first up, the well overflow and water reservoir.
A big open, grass field with a lot of brambles.
This is how I made my way to the field.
A big eucalyptus tree, and a pine tree.
Some ruin there?
Lots of spiky bushes!
I climbed up to the stone ruin...
Cool old ruin!
Something burned there...
It looks a bit collapsed.
Many more native trees around here!
Less mimosas, which is good.
Some roof tiles?
Another sort of ruin.
Now, we are here under the trees.
Big old pine trees!
Another ruin?
It looks very low.
Hard to access...
That's the border with our land, with the poles.
This is really right at the edge!
Another big old pine tree with actual pine cones.
It's a shame it burned down...
It must have been nice to have this big tree.
Not anymore...
Here, I found the burned pine tree.
Making my way back to the ruin...
And, back on the big field.
I'm going to see that side.
Here's some sort of a weird, dead, big, open field?
With a lot of eucalyptus, actually.
And, pine!
Here's the path I travelled to the weird eucalyptus field.
A grass patch.
Random...
It's quite a big height difference here.
Kind of cool!
Another little grass patch...
With many nice flowering bushes.
This is the location of the smaller field.
It's very peaceful here!
Okay, back to our land here.
We are back in the big field.
A cool big rock!
Another burnt tree...
So, here is the big rock.
And there, you can see the big rock from our land!
Cool!
Here's our big grass patch.
It's some cool land!
And, here is the big rock.
Nice adventure exploring this hectare!
I hope you got a rough idea of this place!
So, today we're going to brush cut on the land.
We're going to clean up the bushes,
and the vegetation.
To see what's underneath all of the rocks, the ruins, the well...
I'm kind of curious to see what's all there!
So, it's time to chop some bushes!
So, here we are, in the open space of the land.
I think there's a wall all the way there, but I'm not sure...
So, I thought:
''Maybe I'll start with that one.''
To open it up, and to see what's underneath.
A lot of brambles on top...
So, this could already take me a day,
to just brush cut it...
So, this oak tree was fully covered with brambles.
Now, it fell down and because of the weight...
It couldn't hold itself.
So, now, we're going to put up a rope,
to make sure it's up again and so it can grow.
I got an old mimosa and a hammer.
We're going to give it some extra support,
so it can stand up and become a big old tree!
The wall is now cleared up!
It's still quite rough, with sand and brambles and stuff...
But, that's for later!
At least, we can now see what is actually there.
It's pretty cool!
It's nice to have a terrace is on the land!
Here, you can see the chopped field from above.
Here's the wall that makes it a terrace.
It was probably used to grow vegetables,
and this is the oak tree.
I hope it will survive...
This is the sound of defeating spiky bushes.
Sounds good, when they're all dry and squeezed.
So, here's the area we just chopped, and I realized actually
that the well should just be here...
A lot of vegetation there.
But, I think it's very green,
because there's a lot of water there.
I think I am going to chop here,
and see if we can find that well.
So, it looks like it's here!
Let me show you!
Some little stairs there!
Here's a basin in the overflow from the well.
And then, there is the pathway.
I think it's cleaning up some more, to see what's all there!
It's now cleaned up!
Let me show you some things we found.
A pretty cool old wall here!
The overflow from the well,
with the water coming out here.
It's bit covered with stuff...
Here's some old steps they made from stones.
I think there is the regulator.
Not sure what for...
And then, the water flows here...
It gets more wet, and there's a big basin.
Where the water stays.
It looks pretty cool!
So, here's the chopped road through the spiky bushes.
There you can see the basin of the well overflow.
So, next, we're going to do this grass patch in the middle.
Because, the grass is getting pretty high,
and some brambles start to grow.
We're going to chop this all smooth.
Then, we go to the ruin.
So, the field is now all chopped,
and now we're going to continue there to the ruin.
The last part!
So, here it is!
A big rock in front, some roses...
They need a bit help here!
Everything is now cleaned up around the ruin.
Now, we can have a look and explore a little bit!
We can have a fully walk around the ruin here.
Some nice big old granite rocks!
Over here, I wanted to chop it, but it all
had these blossoming roses, so I could not.
I could not...
Maybe later.
I think it used to be the hinge of the door...
A lot of tiles on the floor...
Probably because the fire burned the wooden beams,
with the roof tiles on top.
So, the wood is gone,
and the roof tiles are here.
It seems like it was a double floor.
Some metal chains?
I don't know what happened there.
Some traces from the fire, with some molten aluminum?
Jars and glass...
It's like the ruin itself is built on
this big granite stone right here.
Yes, this is some of the burnt roof.
Another plate to eat on...
Some metal door lock...
Another thing...
Up here, we have a molten rain coat or something hanging?
Yeah, something molten...
Fabric.
Over here is a big, cool, flat rock.
One of the neighbors actually told us,
that they used to dry their corn here on this flat rock.
Maybe this was also some sort of storage?
So, yeah, that's the ruin!
A pretty nice location with the big rock outside!
It seems like a fun project to renovate.
So, finally, we're going to have a look at the two ruins there.
Those are also the ones I didn't really see properly yet...
Because, the rest was a bit more accessible.
But, this is really dense...
It's a lot of vegetation here.
Let me show you actually.
So, yeah, and somewhere there, or there...
I'm not sure.
So, we're just going to start chopping the pathway,
and hopefully we'll find it!
Sorry!
So, let me show you what we found here in this ruin.
It's also built on a big granite rock,
and the ruin itself is in a bit rougher condition...
It's more like clay and smaller stones.
Looks like there was a small window there.
There's another one there, like a door.
So, it looks like there was a double floor.
If we go out...
There's another little room here,
and it's very low.
I'm not sure, if there's just a lot of stuff here,
like roof tiles and stones.
Well, it was just a little room.
Small room.
Bigger room!
So, this is one sort of ruin.
And then, here's the other building from bricks,
and it has three of these small rooms.
Three cool rooms!
They could be three bedrooms.
As you can see, it was also built on granite,
so maybe it was an older ruin before...
They put bricks on top, what they often do here.
Also here, you can see the granite.
Yeah, these look like three pretty cool places!
So, that was everything to be found on the land for now!
Wow! A big crack there!
Anyways...
I don't know what comes after this!
So, those were the last two ruins on the land.
Well, I think...
That's all we could find!
It's still quite hidden from above.
But, you can actually access it pretty well from the bottom!
That's all on the middle land
We have the wall, the grass patch, the well,
granite ruin, brick ruin and another ruin.
Still more to explore,
but for now we know enough.
So, that's kind of the story of the middle land!
And, up until now, we still didn't officially buy it.
But, we're just going to continue to take it into our plans.
Because, we have trust and faith,
that we will work it out with the neighbor.
This is actually going to be quite an essential land
for Project Kamp, because it's really the center!
So, the long term plan would be that we
move the living situation to this land more.
And, the current Basekamp will become more of a workspace area.
You actually can see more of these plans in the research module!
And, for now, the first next step is we're going
to make an access area, so that we can bring a pig trailer here.
We're going to build our first Level 2 house,
and that's actually going to be the next video!
If you already want to see that,
make sure to support this on Patreon!
Or not, and subscribe,
and you will see it popping up on YouTube.
Thanks for watching!
See you in the next video!